I'm going to introduce the two types of  bar models we have the part card hole  some people refer to it as part hole and  it is a single large quantity with the  total let's sit on top and arrows  indicating the length of that total or  the quantity amount and then we have it  broken into two separate pieces the part  and the other part you can have more  than two parts however and then we have  any comparison model which has two  separate quantities or more you have the  larger quantity a smaller quantity and  you have the difference and then on the  outside here you have a total bracket  which some people call the huggie bear